he did what you are a man you owe the
book he said
suzette sitter valdes these are the orders
i will not do it we man u
otherwise he will cheat on you your school or
there is no french they ask that at the
close
the wii what are you doing on the
set facing the Vaudois asks and
I try to make room for my students
you don't want to learn to read anymore we
're kicking you out of him
why are you taking care of him
c  was at the advances for us my head
you killed men who were
surrendering it's a war crime of
ends we can so much in the party but your
life my departure in the summer for the ditches we
were weapons right now to
bring us  french
touba who kills your cousin class way
it's the law
m
but with